>> ISN'T REALLY THAT INSANE TO
THINK THAT I CAN LAND THE PLANE.
EXPERTS FROM AN UNIVERSITY IN
NEW ZEALAND, IT'S A REAL COUNTRY
, FOUND THAT MEN WERE
MORE CONFIDENT THAN WOMEN IN
THEIR ABILITY TO LAND A PLANE
AFTER WATCHING A A SINGLE HOW-T
YOUTUBE VIDEO.
I USE TO FEEL THE SAME WAY AFTE
WATCHING OPEN HEART SURGERY
VIDEOS ON WEBSITES.
THAT'S HARDER THAN IT LOOKS AS
CLIENT UNCLE STEVE, YOU CAN'T.
NOW ALTHOUGH BOTH WE'RE
OVERCONFIDENT COMMITMENT RATED
THEIR CONFIDENCE 12 POINTS
HIGHER OUT OF A WOMEN OUT OF 10
THAN WOMEN DID.
OF COURSE THAT'S MATH SO WE
ALREADY LOST HALF THE AUDIENCE.
IT ALL MAKES SENSE, IF WOMEN
WERE BUSY LANDING THE PLANE, WH
WOULD BRING ME MY DRINKS AND
PRETZELS?
ANOTHER SEXIST MIGHT SAY, BUT
THERE ARE SEXISTS EVERYWHERE,
THIS PLACE IS FILLED WITH THEM.
>> THEY'RE ALSO APPARENTLY
RACIST TO GO WITH SEXIST BECAUS
THIS IS A WHITE THING.
WE DON'T LEAVE OUR SEATS, WE
TRIED TO FIND OUR WAY OUT FOR
THE FRONT OF THE PLANE HITS
FIRST.
NO BROTHER IS GOING TO THE FRONT
.
WE WILL LET THE G WILL OCCURS,
YOU GO AHEAD, BRO, I'M GOING TO
STAY BACK HERE WITH MY WIFE AND
ENJOY MYSELF BEFORE WE ALL GO
OUT.
>> THAT DOESN'T ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
I WANT TO KNOW.
>> I'M TELLING YOU, NO BLACK MA
IN HIS RIGHT MIND IS GOING TO G
TO THE FRONT OF THE PLANE.
ISN'T LANDING A PLANE DIFFERENT
THAN LANDING A PLANE ON A
COMPUTER.
YOU GET YOUR AIRSPEED AND YOU
FIGURE IT OUT.
I FEEL LIKE THE LADIES WOULD DO
BETTER AT THIS.
PARALLEL PARKING A PLANE MIGHT
BE MORE DIFFICULT.
THANK GOD YOU AND I ARE GOING T
LOOK LIKE STRAIGHT AS THEY COME.
>> WHAT AN UNCOMFORTABLE POINT.
>> IS IT JUST THAT MEN ARE
COCKIER?
>> I DO UNDERSTAND THIS PROBLEM.
MEN ARE PRONE TO THIS.
LOOK AT THE HEIMLICH MANEUVER,
WHERE YOU GO TO GRAB SOMEBODY I
A RESTAURANT, WHENEVER ANYONE
COPS, EVERYBODY WANTS TO
HEIMLICH MANEUVER BECAUSE THAT'
THE ONE THING THEY KNOW.
THE SAME WITH THERE WAS A
MEDICAL THING WHERE THEY WERE
ALWAYS SOME TO GET STUNG BY A
BEE IN THAN THEY APPARENTLY AND
I KNOW IN ENGLAND, THE INDOLENC
PEOPLE SAID THEY WHERE, MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC YOU DON'T KNOW
WHETHER TALKING ABOUT COMING
OVER INSEIN BECAUSE I'VE SEEN I
A LOT ON TELEVISION.
WE THINK WERE EXPERTS WHEN WE'V
SEEN IT ON THE BOX.
BEST NOT TO TRY THAT ON THE
PLANE.
>> I VOLUNTEERED TO DO CPR ALL
THE TIME, BUT THE SOURCE.
KAT, WHAT YOU THINK OF THIS,
MORE SEXISM, MORE OVERCONFIDENT
MEN?
WOULD YOU LAND THE PLANE?
>> KNOW.
BUT I DO FEEL THIS WAY WHEN I
WATCH PEOPLE DO FOOD CHALLENGES
THOUGH.
I'M LIKE I COULD EAT 8800 POUND
ALL OF RAMEN.
IF I DON'T EAT MY VITAMINS I GE
REALLY HUNGRY.
>> ALSO, WHAT KIND OF PLANE ARE
WE TALKING ABOUT I CHI DON'T
KNOW IF I WAS IN THAT.
BECAUSE IT WAS MEANT TO BE TO
LAND AUTOMATICALLY.
>> ONE OF THOSE PROP PLANES.
>> IS THAT THE BEATLES WERE THA
GREAT.
>> I THINK ABOUT THAT EVERY TIM
I LOOK AT YOU.
>> APPARENTLY STEALING MY.
>> IT'S QUITE A CATALOG OF
CRIMES.
>> ARE WE GOING TO A COMMERCI